can you imagine bloodborne too
[Music]
a few months ago i put two and a half
grand on offer
to help artists bring their vision to
life
some took us to the deep seas and some
took us to the heavens
some kept it really faithful they built
upon the foundations of yharnam
and others took risks taking us to
western settings
eastern settings aztec laurent
sesame street view enough entries like
this
and you'll start to grow some eyes on
the inside i'm telling you
but before we begin for the very first
time i'd like to reveal
soul arts a tribute to all of the most
outstanding pieces
contributed to these art competitions
the cover art is by ricardo amike
and it shows all of our artists clawing
for a top position
pouring their souls onto the canvas
see if you can spot all the little
character references one day soon we
hope to bring seoul arts to kickstarter
so
please keep an eye out for that now
though it's time for the top 10.
so let's begin in lauren this
sand swept stormy labyrinth is one of
bloodborne's most
signature chalice dungeons many artists
expanded the world of bloodborne
in this direction including rex beck who
designed a boss
a dark beast named khan kur who was left
behind to guard the gateway
as his masters retreated further
underground
he appears still statuesque surrounded
by a ring of candles and the bones of
former offerings
all manner of creatures kneel before him
worshiping at a safe distance
only when you step beyond the candle
ring does he finally move
but he is stuck in the doorway so the
first phase of the fight has you
chipping away at his arms
as the fleshy growths on the walls
threaten to drag you towards him
after a certain amount of damage kanko
becomes enraged
flaying himself as he tears through the
doorway with electrified wings
created by ripped skin and viscera the
fight begins in earnest
when the boss is slain the flesh
covering the doorway withers
letting through this rush of stagnant
filthy air
now you're free to discover what truly
became of the ancient people of laran
and you receive this cute cosmetic item
for your messengers
for your troubles next we go seabourn
the way zachary introduces his entry is
really powerful
we see a ship being pulled into a
maelstrom followed by a man on a beach
with the wreckage of countless ships
behind him this
high-backed chair is actually a
reference from one of bloodborne's alpha
tests
a warp chair where characters once took
their rest
i let me guess your ship got snatched up
by a foul storm
pulled down to the darkest depths in
that case i'm afraid your crew went down
with the ship
you should consider it a mercy really
something about this place
well you can't sleep not ever
so i sit here very very quietly
in a sort of sleepless dream as for me
confederates
well you'll see yeah take my hook safe
and my pistol you'll be needing them
more than i
the weapons themselves play into the
crude yet crafty tools of a pirate
the hook safe is a sickle with a
detachable pommel that can be swung
around
in tandem with the blade in your other
hand is herman's harpoon pistol
which syncs well with the high mobility
of a bloodborne game because it allows
you to
repel between enemies in a fight you'll
use these weapons to take out the pale
blood priests
islander cultists that have been
transformed by their devotion to the
moonless
child they search unendingly for
precious blood to nourish their decrepit
god
and when they've sucked enough blood
they will swell and harden
into a cocoon-like state emerging as a
proto-amygdala
soon after number eight yong yi lee
in his vision of bloodborne 2 you awaken
and you immediately face off against a
boss
this is the descendant of a great one
part-based
part celestial attacking you with a
combination of attacks
like the nightmare tailblades a ghostly
extension of its forked tail
towards the end of the fight the great
one evolves or devolves really
into afrida a descendant of the pharaoh
she's becoming more human and she
appears to have lost a lot of her ranged
cosmic attacks as a result of that
so instead she throws her surrogate
children
at you these children trip you up they
slow you down
and some even erupt in blood spikes if
you get too close
when you defeat her she devolves fully
back to a human
and her heart reveals that she is
something of an experiment
half beast half celestial much like
yourself
you inspect your own body afterwards and
you discover one arm encrusted with
coral and barnacles
and the other being wrapped and
sprouting hair
you feel power surging from both arms
but each of them feel drastically
different
as if they are of two worlds one high
above ground and the other deep below
the ocean this allows you to make use of
the ancient
axe kopesh which is the star of yong's
entry
the kopesh is a quick slashing weapon
that can be slid into the axe head
for more devastating heavy attacks the
detail on the axe head is amazing and
the concept is strong
but it gets even better because you can
wield this weapon
in beast mode or celestial mode if you
grasp the kopesh by the blade and
attach the hilt to the axe then your
blood will run down
from the blade and activate its beast
mode this is now a crescent axe that
erupts with blood and while every swipe
reduces your health because you're
grabbing the blade
every successful hit actually restores
it if you need even more range
you can activate the celestial mode
instead which extends the weapon into
this powerful scepter where you can
swing
arcane bolts with every strike and just
like its beast equivalent you can also
shorten it down
as well this was such an excellent entry
and honestly
one of the strongest trick weapon
designs that you'll see today
next we dive into deep ford an
underwater take on bloodborne
by holdsworth hands in this world
hunters expressed a desperate desire
to escape the control of the great ones
above seeking the refuge offered by the
deep seas
early expeditions failed hunters were
not prepared for the ocean
and the first suits that they made for
their journey were clumsy and
poorly designed over time they developed
these diving bells
aptly named structures that provided a
place to breathe
and rest on the long descent below can
we just take a moment to appreciate how
genius this design is
as a checkpoint they're a giant bell
with a small lamp attached
the inverse of bloodborne's checkpoints
which featured a large lamp with
small bells attached so the hunters
adapted
and as they delved deeper they developed
helmets that could stand even greater
pressures
let's give a shout out here to the
clever designs of these helmets
and to the ui design as well to their
dismay
normal blood vials didn't work
underwater piercing the suit wasn't a
good idea
so a special valve and a pressurized
blood canister
was implemented trick weapons are here
too of course
any objects that they found below were
fashioned into weapons
such as henry's lost anchor which
extends via a chain mechanism
to form a heavy flail in order to parry
a harpoon pistol can stun your enemies
and pull them to you to perform a
visceral attack
these innovations led hunters deeper and
deeper some traveling so far that no one
ever saw them again
what did they find in the deepest depths
of the ocean what sort of horrors could
stand this darkness
these pressures you pass many hunters
locked
in suits that have become their grave
and there are more and more curiosities
below
4. the ocean is more ancient than the
mountains
and freighted with the memories and the
dreams of time
but the deep seas weren't the only
places hunters could escape
to some found refuge in nightmares
this is karl hassler's nightmare
settlement
a small colony for lost souls founded by
carroll the first settler
this is a place for hunters to rest to
talk to other refugees use the workshop
and
of course be granted strength in
exchange for blood echoes
h.p lovecraft wrote amazing stories
about the traversal of dreamlands
featuring characters who get lost in a
series of unsettling adventures
and i really get that same lovecraftian
sense from this place
as opposed to the hunter's dream which
is small and
disconnected this nightmare settlement
feels like it's actually within
a wider nightmare world full of dangers
and unfamiliar places the hunter's dream
is safe and cozy
yeah but this nightmare settlement feels
like
a safe place in a dangerous world and i
feel like
it's all the more striking for it within
this place you meet
garad a hunter by the looks of it and if
you travel back up to yharnam
you'll find the old city even more
difficult to traverse
than you remember as only the fiercest
beasts have been
able to survive pilgrim beasts that echo
the design of the cleric beast
a ravenous crows speckled with countless
little eyes
and unseen hunters i feel like this
is one of the strongest enemy designs in
the whole competition
your eyes are drawn first to its head
which echoes the design of the moon
presence
next you dissect that tangle of
tentacles to
discover that it actually has four
smaller arms on top
and is supported by one enormous arm
below
here your eyes finally fall upon a
decapitated wolf's head
that lies on the ground you aren't the
only hunter of beasts out tonight
amazing work congratulations to karl
hassler on sixth place
the next three entries expand upon the
stories of the vilebloods
from the original game as you may recall
the vilebloods were born when a scholar
at byrgenwerth brought forbidden blood
back to cainhurst castle
the church considered them a threat to
the purity of their blood healing
and the executioners murdered every last
fowlblood
except for their queen who appeared to
be immortal
in janine magneto's entry queen annelise
smiles as she sits patiently
in her lonely throne room and she speaks
the words
cainhurst will rise again for
unbeknownst to the executioners
some vilebloods managed to escape the
massacre by boat
unfortunately instead of being reviled
for their blood
they actually became hunted for their
blood instead
we play as one such vile blood no longer
a hunter
but the hunted drinking blood offerings
and fending off pirates
the biggest gameplay innovation here are
blood weapons
conjurations similar to those used by
lady maria
which can be used to grab drag bind
repost
and even infect enemies but these aren't
the only blood weapons in janine's entry
there are also two legendary weapons
that are forged from the eyes of
vile blood one day a sailor met miyari
of our blood she fell in love with the
sailor and offered him her blood through
her tears
once the sailor tasted miyari's blood
however his lust could not be sated
he wanted more miyari offered him an eye
in an attempt to satiate him
and he forged it into an elegant weapon
using its infectious powers to conquer
other ships on the seas tragically his
renown with this legendary weapon led to
rumors about the power of vilebloods
and miyari was hunted down her other eye
taken
and hastily forged into a crude weapon
which damages both the player
and the enemy miyari was encased in
stone
a stone that endlessly produces blood no
one knows if she's still
alive in there waiting to be freed one
location we explore is the town of aram
marus which worships the water and all
that comes from it
so when the vilebloods came corrupting
the waters with their blood
the townsfolk were among the most
affected mutating in terrible ways
janine's approachable playful art style
really shines through
on this slide she created npcs that
serve as these
really memorable merchants blacksmiths
and characters
next returning to the top ten for the
fourth time
is jane lysa and as always she goes
above and beyond in bloodborne queen
anneliese partakes in blood drag
offerings
so that she may one day bear a child of
blood
well in jane's entry we play as that
vile blood child
born with a hunter's instinct from all
of the hunter offerings
and born as an immortal which obviously
suits the gameplay of bloodborne
perfectly
the first location we explore is quite
similar to the streets of yharnam
and here at a lit window we talk to our
first npc
two children are behind the window and
they tell a story about their sick
mother who desperately needs medicine
luckily rich nobles have offered them a
great sum of money to dance at their
mansion but we'll get to that later
when you die you awaken at a hunter's
dream its atmosphere is familiar
yet its function is different it
operates as an observatory for the stars
with a large telescope that our new
maiden makes frequent use of
unlike previous hub maidens this one is
cheerful even sarcastic at times
her design is brilliant and her attire
perfectly captures that
vow blood aesthetic since our story
revolves around
learning more about our origins the
first place we walk to
are the torment gardens founded by
exiled vilebloods
here the nobles drown in sin caging
their victims draining their blood
and even turning the prettiest ones into
dolls
the exiled vilebloods wish to become
great ones and in this next scene
they put on performances to please urden
a great one who
is interpreted as existing in sound form
tragically here we fight the twins that
we met earlier in the streets
drained of blood and turned into dolls
the cut scene to follow shows a rune
being tattooed on their bodies by
someone with very sacred knowledge
and the key that you find here leads you
to the next area
the spiritual center here insight starts
to play a greater role in the story
a high priestess reads your fortune with
tarot cards
offering you the hanged man card sensing
what you're about to witness
the room behind her presents an enormous
ouija board inscribed with runes
the boss name appears and reads
runesmith carol
who the first game established as the
creator of the runes we use
here his runes on the battlefield are
randomly activated throughout the fight
buffing him with various new strengths
as the fight runs long
i love this idea it would make the boss
feel different for everyone who
encounters it
at the end we find a wall where carol
tried to transcribe the utterings of the
great ones
we touch an egyptian looking symbol and
we're transported to
lauren where the queen venerated the old
blood and spread the beastly scourge
her right leg is prosthetic based on the
belief that
beast blood creeps up the right leg but
prosthetic legs did nothing to stop the
scourge
in fact the queen came to embrace the
old blood
introducing blood rituals to her people
and making
laran fall even harder as a result
later on we come across a lost beach and
an abandoned ship
this is the captain's nightmare where we
learn the truth behind our origins
turns out this captain hid you the child
of blood
and then stole away with your mother
queen anneliese to draw their enemies
away
after defeating the captain who's lost
in this endless nightmare
you open the chest to find queenly flesh
that's revivable remnant of queen and
elise
the first ending of jane's bloodborne 2
has you being reborn in the waters
surrounding the hunter's dream
however throughout the game you might
have collected blood ethers
which unlock the second and third
endings these have you
either merging with or facing off
against your doppelganger
a great one's projection of yourself
offering incredible power
to match your vile blood legacy the
window in the backdrop of this fight
represents an iris and jane uses it as
the central element of her final art
piece
which features a plethora of weapons
references
and symbols to represent to your journey
uh game developers
are you seeing this can we get these
artists some job offers please
moving into the top three we have
titanilla pittsford's
city of valdenarm this old city was
built upon the surface of the sea
which feeds its canals and inspires this
sense of
venetian gothic architecture the
atmosphere in the city
is familiar yet distinct drawing
really clever inspiration from the
colorful rice powder wig era
of the 18th century with its carnivals
and
masquerade balls it's so genius to pull
that
era into bloodborne's unique brand of
horror
and it fits the law here so well too
favel danam
is described as the city of the
vilebloods who serve
as its ruling dynasty here various
factions clash
and have clashed in the past with the
executioners of the church
but now a new threat has arisen to drown
out the others
one day as a grand masquerade was being
celebrated in the streets of the city
an ancient tide of blood arose and swept
over everything
infecting survivors and setting the
stage for the tumerians to emerge from
the city's
secret catacombs and the tumerians seem
to know it was coming
in fact right before the first tide a
tumerian noble
was blending in with the crowds seeking
blood sacrifices for his masters
with skin resembling a shriveled corpse
he was not exempt from the curse of the
old plague
but his hand and weapon fused together
in a massive tentacles that
allow him to unnaturally extend his jab
in addition to his mysterious arcane
sword that stuns the player if you get
hit
he's fond of tossing oil urns at you and
then spitting fire at them to turn you
into a living bonfire
finally an npc tells you that this noble
might
visit you in your dreams and if he
catches you in a nightmare
he will catch you in reality roaming the
streets of valdenarm are the humming
ladies
young maidens who once longed for love
and excitement at the grand masquerade
her presence is indicated by a soft
echoing melodic humming
she is slow moving almost gliding on the
cobblestones
speeding towards the player with a cage
of messengers extended
hoping to lure you in her humming
becomes louder
and blood orbs shoot towards you unless
you close the distance
which will trigger her lightning fast
transformation
spider legs erupt from below her body
distorts
and the mouth concealed by her wig
threatens to devour you
she's lightning quick and hungry but
that's her weakness
if you lure her to the corpse of a
previously defeated enemy
then she can't help but devour it giving
the player a few seconds of advantage
while she's distracted throw a molotov
at her because it's the only time
that you'll be able to exploit her
weakness to fire another enemy that you
might hear
before you see is the lost servant of
brisenton
whose chains wrankle and clank as he
plods throughout the blood-soaked
streets
crying out in search of his father he's
actually not aggressive
and is able to be passed if the hunter
leaves him alone
but if you don't then you're almost
certain to die on your first encounter
two long arms swipe down at you two
shorter arms attempt to grab you
and his powerful hind legs can propel
him above and behind you
where he may sink his pointed teeth into
your neck he is however very sensitive
to lightning attacks and
if you get him down to a lower health
then he will fight more cautiously
whipping his long neck chain at you from
a distance
of all the entries valdenarm feels the
most
realistic in terms of what fromsoftware
could do with a sequel
it feels familiar yet distinct and the
gameplay considerations here are just
so masterful that i'm honestly kind of
gutted that
we might never get to explore these
venetian blood-soaked streets
titanilla has entered multiple past
competitions
and it's so well deserved that she's
broken the top three here for the first
time
please go and check out her art station
in the description her character art as
you can tell is fantastic
and she's currently open for commissions
if you want to see more
like this now for the very first time we
have a shared
first place congratulations to thomas
chamberlain
and sam lamont first let's explore sam's
world
his is perhaps the most outlandish
piece in the whole competition such was
the wonder of blood ministration that we
were compelled to bring that knowledge
to those unfortunates
who live without its miraculous effects
this was the healing church's mission
as proposed by sam lamont in his world
the healing church sets off to spread
their doctrine to the wider world
but on the way the ships and their
passengers
are irreversibly changed by the
harvesting of
chorus whales whose flesh and blood
reveal terrible insights now we can see
looking upon the stain of warping death
that we leave in our wake
it is not a miracle we bring but terror
and unstoppable ruinous change
sam's game takes place on these
gargantuan ships
which are essentially floating cities
that travel as a fleet
the first we row up to is the thimble
winter sporting these great
lighthouses that shine through the
eternal rain and fog
this ship becomes our hub world but it's
also occupied by the lamplighters who
are these
former crew members tasked with
maintaining the lighthouse
they were irreversibly changed by the
use of oil
that was flenced from the great whales
so a sickness took them
and they began staring endlessly into
the light laughing joyously as their
transformation began
in game they pour oil on you and then
ignite you by spitting
a burning liquid from their mouth so
keen are they to watch
things burn each ship boss drops a
phonograph cylinder
which can be used to play songs that
control the weather
or the tides songs of the void change
the weather
increasing your likelihood of
encountering certain enemies
this adds replay value to each ship
there are also songs of the tides
which can be played to bring new ships
into your fleet
opening up new areas for exploration the
first to be boarded
are the twin ships of dawn and dusk a
twisting labyrinth
left to rot by its blind inhabitants
swarms of gulls once circled overhead
but
when the plentiful fish they were
accustomed to were depleted by the
massive boat's endless trawling
the starving gulls pecked and clawed at
the fisherman's eyes
blinding each and every one who can say
how a bird interprets the insights that
are gained by so many eyes
encounter them and they will vomit
hundreds of eyes at the player
if you were hit the gull's true form can
be seen for a fleeting second
which causes massive frenzy damage in
this place we acquire the trident bow
a whale hunting tool turned trick weapon
capable of firing and then reeling in
your prey
we also find the crescent hook which can
contract into a stabbing weapon
capable of delivering a poisoned jab
next
the song of the waxing crescent brings
us to the brilliant communion
a ship reserved for father ruben and his
clergy
ironically it now seems lost to members
of the occult
nuns turned to witches armed with these
enormous
flencing shears for skinning the chorus
whales
these weapons are incredibly powerful
but their shoddy construction
means that once they break they cannot
be repaired and used again
fall to a flinching witch and your skin
will be added to their cloak
increasing their eldritch powers the
whales themselves are hauled onto the
cornucopia a trawling vessel that was
hastily converted
to accommodate the whales that crewmen
were becoming
increasingly dependent on their whale
skin gave up
whale blubber which permanently
increases either your hp
or your stamina their flensed oil has
miraculous healing properties
and can burn bright enough to penetrate
any fog
within their bowels was ambergris with
a smell that proved irresistible to most
sailors
breaking their minds with terrible
insights if they ate it
finally the whale songs were inscribed
on wax
cylinders made of ambergris so that the
songs of the fathomless depths
could be played on a phonograph after
being administered with the healing
blood these whales gave up their secrets
in flesh
blood and song and as you fight one
during this boss fight
wounds reveal a cornucopia of eyes
underneath
which can blast the player with arcane
beams and when the deed is done
one may fashion a cutlass from a tooth
the natural oils
fueling a flame you can tease from its
edge once the chorus whale is defeated
the player makes their way
inside witnessed by a tunnel of a
thousand eyes
isn't this just the most bloodborne
thing you've ever seen the eyes coalesce
into a sea of stars and galaxies
eventually leading to the final area
the city underneath here the true forms
of the chorus whales float overhead
with an alien grace circling a spire
suggestive of the deep sea rune where
each tower
ends with a fight against the heralds
who listen to the rituals being
performed above
after the last one is slain you were
transported to a chalice dungeon
surrounded by tumerians who speak to you
in a language you
inexplicably understand they have
answered
you can find more work from sam over on
his website moonskinned.co.uk
where he's only too happy to give form
to expansive worlds
intricate games and horrifying monsters
he even sells a small set of miniatures
in his store which
he thinks should appeal to the dark
souls fans among us
so please go and check him out in the
description
sharing first place with sam is thomas
chamberlain
who masterfully captures the themes the
aesthetics and
also just the design goals of from
software injured
you wander the desert seeking blood
healing until you notice a figure
in the distance pulling a makeshift pram
upon getting closer
they turn to face you and if you look
past the enormous scythe
you may notice something familiar about
them right before they cut you to shreds
this is not a fight you're supposed to
win but delay your demise long enough
and the figure will use eldritch attacks
granting you
some insight to start your journey with
you awaken in the hunter's reverie
a sort of daydream equivalent to the
hunter's dream
i love the colour palette and the
atmosphere of this place
patiently waiting as you admire the new
dream is the doll
she's no longer hostile to you but her
newfound tendency for violence
and conflict does help to explain her
newly cracked facade
doing character development for the doll
is a brilliant idea
and it continues as you interact with
her you can ask to look inside her pram
and she'll refuse but if you keep trying
with your weapon drawn
then she will eventually relent you
quickly learn that
her warnings are not to be taken lightly
because looking inside will grant you 20
insight
but at the cost of 50 percent of your
maximum health
attack her and the doll will ask if you
wish to leave this place
continue and she'll curtsy booting you
to the main menu screen
which you kind of deserve let's be
honest on the flip side
you can bring her certain clothes that
you find throughout your journey
and for this she will thank you and be
seen wearing them
in subsequent visits gaining trust with
the doll will reward you with weapons
broaches and she might even assist you
in the final fight
for there is a brooding disturbance in
the depths of lauren
the sand is draining away somewhere
beneath the city exposing the sprawling
ruins
the city is crawling with exadita giant
ticks that languish in the exposed sun
they're your primary source of blood
provided you have a cannula to inject
with different types of cannula can be
found
throughout your journey and these
injection vessels
change the type of healing you receive
for example some replenish more hp but
slowly
and some replenish less hp but quickly
and
some offer buffs to damage speed or
defense
this is such a good idea your garb also
suits the setting
and you'll soon find a fantastic trick
weapon to match
the tendon saber a hooked weapon it's
designed
to sever the achilles tendon it has a
contracted one-handed state for
grappling with enemies
in close range and an extended
two-handed form
intended for long-range defensive combat
it's the weapon our character wields
against the ixida queen
an enormous tick that towers over you
looking for an opening
as you're swarmed by its spawn as long
as the smaller ticks can be taken out
carefully they can be a source of
healing for the player
but carelessness fighting the minions
might put you in range of the queen
whose mouth has this devastating grab
attack
there are two ways you can progress the
fight the queen has high health
regeneration thanks to her huge store of
blood but
it's possible to overwhelm her with
enough consistent damage
alternatively you can repeatedly attack
her blood sac until it ruptures
lowering her health regeneration with
each wave of toxic blood
in her fully depleted state her blood
sac is horrifically severed
and she lets out a nauseating shriek
scaring away the lesser exider
and rushing you in a frenzy with
drastically increased movement
and attack speeds but no matter which
combat approach you take
if you risk focusing your attacks on her
mouth then you'll eventually be rewarded
with the ixida queen
hyperstone it's a trick weapon crafted
from her remains
capable of shooting out this
lightning-fast whip to impale enemies
allowing you to drain them of their
blood just as she does
thomas also drafts four other trick
weapons all sporting
consistently strong designs the pincer
shears
the leeching urumi the ceremonial pick
and the feral makwahuit
as you explore the city the eclipse
overhead progresses
and your insight deepens as a result
enemies get harder
different enemies seem to show up and
you also start to notice visual cues
that help you perfectly time your
dodgers which is similar to what we
received as a gameplay innovation
in sakura i love this i love that he
tied it into insight as well
anyway in this place you speak to the
inhabitants of laran
who are hiding away in their homes
there's talk of a queen
some implore you to trust her a little
longer and some ramble about her dooming
us all
there are violent members of an
insurrection on the streets and who you
decide to side with
plays into the side stories of the city
opening up helpful shortcuts
or providing rare resources so you fight
your way to the deepest depths
and you finally reach the altar of the
lost
ocean a great one sits upon the altar
holding some bloodied remains
wrapped in swaddling cloth you approach
realizing the bodies bent in prayer
are long since desiccated crumbling at
your touch at the altar is another
powerful healing item
the queen's cannula which reads the
people were ailing
plagued by disease and drought a great
power was offered by the tumerian priest
a ritual that when complete could
deliver her poor laurenites from their
torment
she would never come to learn the true
horror she had unwittingly brought
upon the world an unending curse of
defilement
and death taking this item drives the
great one into a frenzy
breaking the altar apart and throwing
you into the abyssal water below
as with many great bodies of water in
bloodborne when you hit it you are
transported into a nightmare and on your
way back up to the surface
in this realm you also encounter the
townsfolk running in fear
or undergoing hideous transformations
and at the surface
you start your final fight with fauna
the great one
of lauren in bloodborne it was
speculated that our moon presence was
called
flora based on some dialogue from the
doll
flora is a technical term for plant life
and fittingly the great one of lauren
is called fauna the technical term for
animal life
so considering laran is famous for
having its own beastly
scourge fauna is an excellent name
after the nightmare is slain the city
seems to be at rest
now that you have the knowledge and the
tools required for blood healing you
travel home to your settlement
and part ways with the doll on your way
out if you have enough insight
you see the doll pusher pram up an altar
to meet with fauna
who is seemingly still alive as fauna
descends the doll gently waves
goodbye and they both disappear from
sight
the end what i love about thomas
chamberlain's entry
are the questions that are left unspoken
as bloodborne fans a lot of you can
probably guess for example what was in
the doll's pram
you can probably see why she's wielding
a scythe you
might figure out why the great one is
wearing a wedding ring
and why it's cradling an infant thomas
doesn't explicitly
explain these things instead he respects
your intelligence
and your curiosity with the way that he
presents them
and that is the most from software-like
trait of them all
thomas is currently a concept artist
over at playground
games and his professional background
shows honestly
his take on the ran would be an
excellent foundation for a team that's
looking to build out gameplay level
design and
lore so if you're looking to learn
thomas has a youtube channel where he
details the processes
behind a lot of his art and he's even
given a long interview
detailing all of the law and design
decisions behind
this piece in particular which i really
recommend you watch
so please check out all of his links
including his art station
in the description congratulations to
everyone who competed
it's a huge privilege to receive and
review your art
and even if your piece wasn't seen here
i hope you enjoyed the creative process
of
competing in the competition before you
go though let's talk about some of these
runner-ups
the most difficult thing about these
competitions is choosing who makes it
into the top 10
and who misses out luckily since an art
book is being made from these entries
it's my hope that that book will do a
lot of justice to a lot of the unseen
art and artists
that said runners-up for this
competition included
pierre who was perhaps the only one to
present bloodborne with a spanish flair
with weapons and attire to match wes
fraser whose greenhouses filled with
healing herbs were
decommissioned after the healing blood
took over
only to be recommissioned in the hopes
of transcending humanity
through the lumen woods nader offered a
convincing story that i thought would
make excellent dlc
featuring edward of the moon and his
many weapons
mark took bloodborne to a forested cove
which was settled by birgenworth
scholars
who later became ruled by pirates and
their terrible captain
john beck whose 3d renders were
unparalleled in this competition
he took us to the hinterlands a murky
wetland full of decay
and rot benjamin proposed a vampiric
flare for his sequel with our character
discovering the corruption within
sauvign castle this entry was so close
to making it in
nolan created the best underwater
concept from a gameplay point of view
with the actual currents being
controllable by the player
getting around the sluggishness of
underwater combat
felix offered an excellent perspective
on a hub
world with their art there was ab and
rain
who are always on the very brink of the
top ten
they presented a set of factions that
were really very convincing
andrew miranov set up characters that
fused bloodborne's aesthetic
with the world war angel created a
really stylish cast of characters
placing really high as always augusto
crossed bloodborne with a knightly
aesthetic which looks awesome
elena created a really memorable boss
called the bloated cardinal
i'll always remember the spring heel
jack from
harrison's super detailed entry there
was ian's retro aesthetic
juwon's awesome painted style maxime
envisioned carol as an owl
chauffan created a awesome aesthetic
inspired by chinese folklore
ascan took us to the western gold rushes
where
miners found and became obsessed by a
very different kind of
metal and aeron proposed a haunting
ritual for his piece
showing a group chanting an ode to the
great one now there's also two other
entries that absolutely would have made
the top 10 but weren't eligible because
they were actually created before the
competition was announced
these are shots from kradichen estani's
blood maidens
and toby treble jars ocean born and
they're astounding i hope they accept a
feature in the art book
but the final uneligible entry is by
ricardo amike
who opted not to return as a judge for
this competition
simply because he wanted to contribute
one last thing
it's a series of art masterpieces
put to video and it serves as a very
fitting end to our competition
so thank you everyone for being a part
of this
maybe one day we'll return for a second
season but for now
enjoy one iron ore by ricardo amike
[Music]
yes
they call the one aeronaut
the wondrous device
[Music]
the grandson one
eyes
[Music]
there at the graveyard of our
achievements
[Music]
tide comes the waters
rise and all
will be taken by the end
most night
those who walk the loose lane
trying to wake themselves by
[Music]
immaculate
[Music]
and upon the crown of creation
lonely stance a galvanist
trying to reanimate
a wilting flower smith
curious
god from the machine
[Music]
and the pilgrims who finally found the
way
four in their
[Music]
the opticon
[Music]
[Music]
will be squashed by the sea
ah what have we created
but worry not
for it will always end i
have begun
[Music]
behold
the rising
sun
[Music]
you